[Music]
you thought forest fires were bad
wait till you hear about ocean fires
yeah that's right the sea bursting into
a fiery hellscape
what if every ocean on earth burst into
flames
how much fuel would be needed to ignite
them
how would this affect our climate
and would the oceans evaporate
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the oceans caught fire
it has happened before
a thunderstorm west of mexico's yucatan
peninsula caused an underwater natural
gas pipeline to leak
electrical shocks from the storm ignited
the gas
lighting the surface of the ocean on
fire
a perfect storm
literally
after five hours of this view
the fire was extinguished but
that doesn't satisfy our curiosity
in our scenario we would spill oil over
our oceans and ignite them all
and if all the oceans caught fire
how long until a massive amount of smoke
and soot
seriously harms people and wildlife
would that mean we'd say goodbye to our
oceans
for all the oceans to catch fire they
would need to be entirely covered in oil
71 percent of earth's surface is oceans
so we need a lot of oil
and it couldn't be a thin layer
otherwise it wouldn't ignite
so for this scenario let's cover the
water with a layer of fuel at least one
centimeter thick
well that means we'd need a total volume
of 3
600 cubic kilometers of oil
that's enough to fill canada's lake
huron
but would there be enough oil in the
world to initiate this bizarre plan
in 2016 the world consumed
5.6
billion cubic meters of oil
but to get this global ocean fire going
we'd need about
645 times that
if the oceans were ablaze the first
nasty byproduct would be black smoke
clogging our atmosphere
this smoke would pose a considerable
health risk because it would be filled
with soot particles
these would penetrate deep into our
lungs causing heart attacks
strokes or even death
4.6 million people die each year from
causes linked to air pollution
with our oceans on fire this number
would be much much worse
the smoke could block out the sun and
cast an eerie brown glow over the earth
vegetation and crops would die
the massive amounts of greenhouse gases
created would help speed up global
warming
eventually the fire would increase the
surrounding air temperatures
this could lead to storms with intense
wind speeds and precipitation
and then there's a planet-changing twist
rising temperatures
would cause ocean water to evaporate if
the fire kept burning
how long until all of our oceans
disappeared
at normal atmospheric pressure pure
water boils at 100 degrees celsius
for salt water this boiling point
increases slightly based on the salt
concentration
if our oceans reached boiling
temperatures
this would lead to a runaway greenhouse
effect the higher the temperature the
faster the water would evaporate and the
more water in the atmosphere the more
heat would be trapped
this never-ending cycle would continue
to raise the earth's temperature and all
the oceans would be gone
completely
and along with them we'd lose all marine
plant and animal species
including phytoplankton the microscopic
plants that float near the ocean surface
performing photosynthesis and releasing
oxygen into the air
phytoplankton create more oxygen than
all the trees on earth
estimates are that they produce 50 to 80
percent of all oxygen on the planet
so in short no more oceans would mean
less oxygen less food and well
fewer humans
whoever could adapt and survive
would be left on a planet almost
completely covered in desert
but there is good news
our fossil fuel reserves aren't capable
of burning all the oceans so unless we
import some interplanetary fuel from an
earth-like planet but we'll be okay
sound fair enough of course
for that you'd need to find another
earth somewhere in the galaxy
earth 2.0
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Applause]
[Music]
you